2013 ou 2014 quelle date pour le
changement de rythme scolaire et pour
quoi faire
ce sont les réponses que recherchaient
les adhérents de la fcpe lors d'une
réunion tenue à trappes ça les cours
reviennent le samedi ou le mercredi les
temps périscolaires comment ils vont
être organisées sur la ville où je vis
est ce que l'enfant sera vraiment au
coeur du débat la relation enseignants
écoles aussi comment ça va se passer
parce que ils vont devoir peut-être
travailler un peu plus toutes ces
questions construit le changement du
rythme scolaire divise si des
municipalités souhaitent attendre 2014
pour passer à la semaine de quatre jours
et demi
les parents d'élèves présents ce samedi
voudrait une application plus rapide
arrêtez de dire on ne peut pas j'y vois
là maintenant on va essayer de le faire
quels sont les moyens comme on peut
travailler tous ensemble pour réussir à
mettre en place tout simple c'est quand
même par par un constat des enfants où
on voit que les enfants en france on a
beaucoup trop d'écoles avec des partners
and under d'école important en semaine
et ça on affiche apposée des résultats
très mauvais surtout les têtes de
lecture refermer train nous ce qu'on
demande c'est de revenir au plus tôt
possible sur ces neuf demi journées
d'enseignement par semaine dans les
écoles et donc la voir dès 2014 les
parents d'élèves se sont aussi
interrogés sur le type d'activités
scolaires et la mise en place de la
réforme dans les écoles privées une aide
financière de l'état de 50 euros par
élève sera accordé aux communes mettant
en place la réforme dès la rentrée 2013
le projet de loi sera examiné mi mars à
l'assemblée nationale